je vous invite maintenant à faire un
détour aux limites de la sculpture et de
la politique en rendant visite à un
artiste polonaise qui a obtenu
exceptionnellement un visa d'une semaine
à paris pour présenter ses oeuvres
elle s'appelle magdalena abaca norwich
beaucoup plus qu'une simple exposition
les oeuvres présentées sont un
témoignage les formes exposés sont selon
l'artiste dépôt successifs dont elle se
débarrasse en marquant les étapes de sa
route dépôt successives
plus précisément des moulages
vous savez j'ai fait un moulage d'un
homme et ensuite quand je faisais le
positif de ce roulage
j'ai découvert que son mouvement nos
mains ne s'explique pas que pour trouver
une forme qui parle suffisamment au
sujet de l'homme je peux bien supprimer
des détails du corps la façon de
laquelle j'ai utilisé la matière est
différente celle ci elle est seulement
dans certaines parties découvertes
elle monte son intérieur celle ci le
montre encore plus ici dix ans
l'intérieur est presque totalement
couverts
cet homme blessé ces objets dépouillé
structure inertes sont ils le reflet
d'une crise de conscience sans parler
politique
les événements d'un pays profondément
bouleversé peuvent-ils influencer le
travail d'un artiste
le été fait avant parce que vous voyez
le dap il y a des cycles sur lequel j'ai
travaillé pendant quatre cinq ans ici et
en plus je dois dire que l'inspiration
elle ne vient pas tellement de
l'extérieur peut-être dans un certain
sens mais elle est avant tout élaboré
dans notre intérieur par notre intuition
par tous nos sentiments et ensuite tout
d'un coup nous voyons quelque chose nous
découvrons quelque chose ensuite on peut
dire cette chose nous avait expiré
nous l'avons trouvée nous d'exposition
elle est au sujet de l'homme au sujet de
la solitude au sujet des problèmes que
je vois dans tout le monde organique de
notre planète auquel nous appartenons à
la multiplication des moulages et
destinée à donner l'impression de foule
contrairement à son habitude l'artiste
ne les a pas disposées en cercle comme
pour les faire communiquer entre eux ici
placé face au mur ils attendent d'être
replacée en rond pour reprendre leur
dialogue imaginaire